[Music]
an art to die for news oh no that's no
no no submitted by Jade Jade Thank You
Jay you sound like a ho lighting up
everybody's name for some reason no the
past three of them we've just been
lighting them up for some random reason
so I just decided Wednesday
oh my bad I'm just kidding actually the
person who watches all the Jake events
it's only been one an artist suffered
mysterious symptoms for years before
realizing her sculpture was poisoning
her oh the material she was using damn
they used to happen a lot back in the
day oh yeah like the wallpaper would
have some [ __ ] beste asbestos that's
not mine and kids were dying and [ __ ]
and they were using it in the Johnson &
Johnson baby powder and so a bunch of
state recently have any like kidding
yeah they're still getting sued just
like they just like to definitively
paste how come the BP oil literally what
it's called
how come during the BP oil spill the
companies that come on be like yo my bad
and they make commercials you know but
how come Johnson Johnson's not like
hi We're dr. Johnson everything is best
those things basically they were like
you can't prove it you can't prove it
you can't prove it again stuffing it
down and all these women like like
hundreds of thousands of women have yeah
super cool I could remember like the
thighs or something right yeah that in
like on they're like on their babies and
they so they were always like you know
using it and breathing it and so like hi
I'm Ted Johnson turns out asbestosis is
pretty bad for your body we didn't know
that and we're gonna be looking at that
like what are you gonna say you did say
it he goes that's a we use but paste on
our butts it really was also doing silly
crap there's a famous like scientist
oh yeah we carry and I forgot
yeah but they've they forgot I'm
carrying no it's Marie Claire Marie
Callender they both got radioactive
poisoning on the stuff that they're
[ __ ] around we're closer was it no
her notebook it's still to this day
super radioactive is that when they they
put on cloth and then we should take off
her glasses she had laser eyes this one
that's Cyclops so what was this lady
sculpture made of so her name is Gillian
no she was using all natural material Oh
funny actually Iranian fresh from the
ground no natural shrooms no so she was
using uh so seashells and why is it her
name's Sally and ethically sourced
animal bones and so those are Hermits
are you laughing at - like ethically
sourced she's not slaughtering animals
exactly the bone the exact she found the
bones in the ground that mean good to
produce bones did it die just for the
artwork don't you love it that's like
when I go to Trader Joe's and it's like
these chickens weren't killed very
nicely they had a great life they were
[ __ ] cold like those like every other
name in that show anyway where they kill
the chicken nicely yeah see where they
put it in the in the cone upside down
did you see that one no anyways I guess
it to kill a chicken a nice way they
take like a street cone with those
[ __ ] orange cones what are they
called yeah yeah upside down and then
they cut the tip off and then they put
the chicken in there upside down and
like kind of pull the head through and
then like they wait for the chicken to
kind of relax and then they like do
something and it kills it like much
faster than so instead of like chicken
had a great life before it's horrible
demise I don't know that's like that's
like hey pedigree like all the horse
meat that we your pets eat was they had
a really great time before they went
into the wood chipper at the end you
know
close it all don't worry this kind of
[ __ ] has hooves and all OH
so Julian here she has been working on
this sculpture for the past 15 years and
she was using mussel shells and that's
what was poisoning her because she would
grind up the mussel shells and like use
it first coat she was creating the
sculpture of Adam the first man and this
whole thing the fact that she got
poisoned is like so deeply ironic
because she was using natural material
to depict a biblical character that she
wanted to comment on humanity's skewed
relationship with the now contaminated
natural world oh that is very ironic and
he kind of said she got contaminated you
never knew what was wrong with her she
was having actually I'll play this video
here I didn't know people could get sick
from mussel shell yeah so what
apparently with these specific mussel
shells once it's broken up and you
inhale it so these mussel shells they
attract metals in the ocean like oh
that's what their job is like to cleanse
the ocean basically yes of them like
when she was cleaning it up and like
inhaling it she was poisoning herself
yeah 15 years for 15 years and later the
symptom I'll play this video she's
talking about it a little bit this is
her sculpture looks sick it doesn't mean
uh seashells she's good I thought I look
like a [ __ ] joke before she knew
scary [ __ ] is a double severe dementia
yeah I couldn't follow my thought oh man
I had confused spatial confusion so I
had difficulty imagining rotating a
piece or understanding where to put it I
would put things on backwards or upside
down like me now point every day I would
go to my studio door
after she read someone's being poisoned
now I could not finish the piece does
she kill working on it even knowing you
didn't know did she die no no
oh [ __ ] but she still suffers from a lot
of complications because of this but she
liked good news it's going up for sale
yeah [ __ ] that I know what's gonna
happen to it no one could be around it
is a wax ceiling or something like that
around it or something like you don't
have to inhale it's probably not talking
just existing as a sculpture cuz people
are around all the time it's just that
you don't grind them up oh that's crazy
right so yeah for years they'd never
knew what was wrong with her and finally
after so many years and 2015 she went to
go see a specialist and they did this
poisoning
I'm flirting rose I don't get to do that
so I'm time fifty she's a specialist who
tested her but her blood for heavy
metals tears like perfect they put on a
scope of arsenic and lead in her system
yeah so she was just like how have I
been poisoned this whole entire time so
then she had to look at everything in
her life and then that's when that
specialist was horrified to find out
that she was using mussel shells for
years it was more horrified that's
helped me write it that's crazy that she
even knew though that the shells were
does that special is not like a marine
biologist or anything yeah but she's a
specialist yeah cancer right testing for
like how many metal poisoning you'll
know like all the different ways like if
you're testing for creed poisoning yeah
pretty quick test yeah metal use the
actual it's just me comet exactly as I
said screed poisoning and that's why
it's also poison I really landed then
that solid lay my bad thank you I like
to create in high school we just say
for you you didn't hear me squeezing my
balls oh I'm doing it I said welcome to
you these please oh do you really I did
still all the judge it's a very nice
basic song yeah basic like if I mean if
you're basic
that's one of the wettest but rock songs
I've ever read so no so but rock is like
wow it's not Creed it's that it's that
[ __ ] numb what's that spider-man to
song I don't know what the [ __ ] everyone
hates on these guys nickel bag to
soundtrack song cream yes it is it some
dripping wet but rock getting so what's
getting [ __ ] wet listening to it why
does your buddy your buckets when you're
turned on white trash dudes and like
dudes in general you know who we're fat
dudes we're Iron Man t-shirts ready
while you're listening to your yeah
you're like going all in to your but I
translate Steve like you translate you
got she's really good no so don't even
come up with that [ __ ] what do you mean
you're sitting at Joe's here to be
translated it's not the chair okay I've
been talking about but Rock for years
it's just a real thing I believe it I
could imagine it yeah well of course
you've been to karaoke before yeah and
and Bart's defending it like you would
through almost every song in karaoke is
Blackrock yeah and it's the favorite the
crowd pleasers the closes what's a
crowd-pleaser
the but rock jams like the one it's like
a song that hates journey is not but
rocks you know what it's damp but rock
it is guess what we're not friends let
me ask you this journey turn do you want
listening to it yes like I said damn you
in a different way very light amount
it's almost like one of those Neutrogena
pads it's like oh it's not that bad you
cannot compare journey to Creed Steve no
no it's it's like Creed is like the
needle is almost gonna break it's like
all the way over here the volume is up
to laughs like like you know journeys
over here hey that's pretty low yeah
let's know that's good listen we're
making a cake right same you're making
it's all it goes into a cake that
doesn't mean it's the seniority I'll
give you journey no ingredients or the
end results not the same you're making a
doughnut or some [ __ ] like we're not
really that's exact what I'm saying
though okay so so doughnuts are made of
the same things that cakes are made of
but donuts have a different reputation
you don't even know what the [ __ ] you're
talking about sorry about doughnuts and
cake and damper it's like what the [ __ ]
is happening so just vertical this is
ridiculous this is me at my purest form
I always talk reddit yeah I mean you
just keep making enemies no I don't
blame Joe Joe Joe is a good man and a
great man and I won't sit here and wait
so this gets added into that subreddit
where we hate each other because I
[ __ ] hate you
how is like
believe it oh and Quinn goes just like
Marie Antoinette's hacking it's a sub
you don't really dig it's Dean I'm
related to I come from the bloodline no
look in the business in the realm of but
rock like that song is like it's not pot
rock at all like you barely write well
that's like this your dick you're a deal
to be your lawyer not but rock what's a
good rock band I vote to end this video
I hope to hear [ __ ] answers good rock
band you have to hear here is answer
first
[ __ ] led [ __ ] Zeppelin
okay that's not a mic every time but
then the same category they are the same
group of all time they're in the same
molecular levels of wetness
[Music]